And I'm very proud of you.
I call it my map book.
We can see what's coming
before it happens.
Iris.
You're going to get pregnant
at three months.
This new speedster
wants to build a time machine.
I swore I would make sure
that we always had a future.
I don't want to know everything
that's going to happen.
I just want to be able to choose it.
You've got them in your hands.
What do we have to lose?
The whole timeline will be at stake.
I need your help to save the world.
I seem to live for
you doing this show. You
done there. But
we can do the impossible.
Flash the students one last time.
Flash final season begins February 8th.
Free next day only on the CW app.
Welcome back, everyone. Is Charlie.
They dropped a new flash
trailer. We'll break it down.
There's a whole bunch Easter eggs.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We obviously have the Flash movie
coming in.
The Super Bowl is happening
in the next couple of weeks.
There'll be a new trailer
for the Flash movie during that as well.
I know there's a ton of questions
about what's happening just in the larger
DC universe in the arrowverse
because of the big James Gunn reboot.
He just released that DC Studios trailer.
I did a much bigger video for it,
so I'll post a link at the end of this
and down in the description below
where he talks about all the new projects,
the movies and the TV series in DC,
Phase one, which they're calling chapters
now, as he says in the trailer here,
this is basically the last run
for the Flash TV show
in a essentially the end of the Arrowverse
Superman.
Lois is still technically part
of the multiverse of the Arrowverse
It takes place on a different earth.
It's not on the same earth as the Flash,
but because the CW basically sold itself
to Nexstar and they're canceling
all the more expensive programs
in most of the Arrowverse
shows, like Next Starz,
the one that's canceling
most of these shows, it sounds like
they also probably canceled Superman Lois
after this current upcoming season
just because it's so expensive to make.
But the biggest villains characters
they're doing during Flash Season nine,
you see most of them during
the trailer. Here is the Red Death.
A couple versions of the Reverse-Flash
are back like Matt Lesher is back.
Tom CAVANAUGH separately will return,
but not as that exact
same Reverse-Flash the Barry killed
at the end of season eight.
Tom Cavanagh has already played a billion
different characters on the show,
so no surprise there.
Eddie Thawne is coming back
and it seems like they're finally
paying off the fan casting for him
as cobalt blue from the comics.
And obviously Stephen Amell
coming back as Oliver Queen
and in the set pics, you actually see him
in classic Green Arrow gear.
So it's not just Specter,
Oliver Queen coming back and using his God
tier powers to fix all Flash's problems
with the snap of his fingers.
This is the video.
Stephen Amell also posted
when he was filming his scenes.
Oh, hey there.
Yeah. Uh huh.
I'm coming back for the ninth
and final season of The Flash.
Why does it matter how
it doesn't matter?
Greg Berlanti called me up
and he said, The Flash's ending.
Would you like to?
And I said, Yes.
You're
going to have to finish your sentence.
I have always, always loved coming over
as Oliver, Queen, Green Arrow, Specter
and Nazi
The Flash, you name it to the Flash.
I love the cast.
I love the crew.
So for Greg Berlanti,
thank you for Eric Wallace.
Thank you for Grant
and Candice and Daniele,
who's directing and the rest of the cast.
Thank you for having me.
Don't ask me any more questions about it.
Just tune in where it airs later
this year.
I love the very nonspecific way
about how he talks about what
he's doing on the show.
Like, I'm not going to say exactly,
but we basically kick a bunch of ass.
We do a bunch of stuff
that you would expect us to do.
Basically, all your theories about what
Oliver does probably somewhat correct.
He's still the specter.
So it means that after whatever they do
when he shows up on the series,
he will go back to being the specter.
There's a bunch of new scenes
with Red Death.
It seems it's
going to be one of the overarching threads
during the season
in a lot of the other bigger characters.
Get involved with that
because he keeps talking about
how the timeline will change.
Like they're trying
to change the entire timeline.
They're trying to build a time machine.
We have to stop that.
Normally, I would say that
Red Death is from the future
because that's the way they tease
the character in previous seasons.
But it sounds like they might be taking
a little more inspiration
from the comic book storyline
where Red Death
was from a different universe,
same basic
time period, but different universe.
And whatever happened
when this version of Batwoman
Fuzed with that version of The Flash
in her universe,
she hasn't been able to use their powers
in the Speed Force to travel through time.
The way that the Flash
would normally be able
to use the Speed Force to travel in time.
That's one of the whole
conceits of the series, is
the Flash does have the ability
to travel in time and has to learn
that he shouldn't be doing that.
Sure, as an ICE timeline would be a shame
if someone messed it up.
They're basically going
to be doing a version of that Flash point
during the Flash movie,
but it's going to be
more of a multiverse spin on that idea.
It sounds like Red
Death is the one that's trying
to change the timeline because in it
you see Barry pull out the future notebook
where he's like, Look at all the things
that are going to happen in the future.
I'm going to give you all these spoilers
about
what's going to happen in the next year.
It really is like his spoilers book
and Iris is complaining about him
giving away spoilers like,
I don't want to know everything
that's going to happen,
I just want to figure it out as it goes
along.
Zoom in Enhanced Notice the 2024 date
that will remind you of the flash Future
newspaper from season
one that we talked about for so long
because it was meant to be a big crisis on
Infinite Earths Teaser Early on the date
April 25th, 2024,
when they did Flash Season one,
when they actually did that
future newspaper
and they teased all these things
and it was meant to be them saying, Oh,
this is going to happen
in the flash season ten
because it was supposed to be one season
every single year.
It was a reference to the comic book
Crisis on Infinite Earths,
where Flash was supposed to vanish
in, quote unquote die.
People believe that he was dead,
but something else happened.
I'll explain in a second.
In real life, they changed that storyline.
They did Crisis on Infinite Earths
a few years before that.
Obviously, I did a ton of videos for that
when it happened,
and because of the big delay
with the virus that meant that
the 2024 date would be flash season nine,
not Flash season ten,
but it was basically meant to be like
the very end of the flash,
the finale of The Flash.
So it kind of is in kind of
isn't at the same time
just because of all the weird delays
that happened
in the way they shifted around crisis
on infinite Earths.
Also, when they did that future newspaper,
the producers of the show never
envisioned what was going to happen with
the big James Gunn reboot of DC in the CW,
basically selling itself to Next Star
and canceling all the Arrowverse shows.
I don't think anybody could have predicted
all of this chaos looming enhanced again
on the Future notebook.
The other reference here to 2024 is
that Iris
West is supposed to open a new branch
of her media business.
The CC stands for Central City
Citizen Media
in Coast City, which is where
how Jordan Green Lantern is from.
James Gunn did announce
a new Green Lantern show on HBO.
But it's going to be a totally different
thing from the one Greg
Berlanti and the Arrowverse
people were working on before this.
The new Green Lantern series
will primarily be just how Jordan and Jon
Stewart with a true detective vibe
that will tie in to the larger Justice
League crossover story that they're doing
in the next several years.
There will be other Lanterns on it,
but they didn't say
when the premiere date is going to be.
So I'll do more videos for that
when we get more information.
The whole Diggle Green Lantern thing
was mostly wrapped up last season.
Now they've had a couple
of different versions of Diggle.
There was one on Superman, Lois,
but that was one
from a Different universe,
completely different version
of the character.
At the end of the day,
the basic idea is that in the arrowverse,
Diggle did not will not become
a version of Green Lantern,
which is kind of a bummer.
It really did seem like they were trying
to tease that for several years.
But then the DC people, the powers
that be basically told the Arrowverse
people, No, you're not allowed to do
Green Lantern, so get rid of this.
Flash tells Iris she's going
to get pregnant with Nora in three months.
We've seen her many different times
at different ages.
The adult version we've seen her
is a baby.
My guess is that during the finale
we'll either see her be born or something
close to that. Like we'll see
or be born during the season.
This is Owen Mercer. He's
the new Captain Boomerang.
He's wearing a more comic book
accurate suit.
He's meant to be
the son of the Digger Harkness
as Captain Boomerang from previous seasons
in that actor, if you saw Stargirl
actually played a version of Eclipse
on that series, we see more of The Flash's
rogue's gallery.
It seems like
most of them are working with him.
They're kind of anti-heroes at this point
when he says
the whole timeline will be at stake.
It just sounds like it's part of the
overall Red Death plot in the Matt LeCHER
Eobard Thawne in Eddie Thorne Cobalt
Blue storyline will be part of that.
The person in the bar is Jill Blaine.
He's back from previous seasons.
He's another cold
based character, is part of Caitlin
Snow's Killer Frost storyline.
They teased the return of Killer
Frost last season.
You kind of see some of that
in the trailer, too.
He started out as a villain
and had a very killer Frost type of story
arc, where he slowly started to become
a better character and help them.
But he's also more of an anti-hero
type of character.
He had a relationship with Killer Frost.
Now she's coming back.
So his storyline is mostly with the killer
Frost character.
A lot of questions about how they're going
to end the show, too.
So early predictions,
like I said, probably teasing Nora
being born or she'll already be born
before the finale.
The Flash is supposed to die sacrificing
himself or everyone thinks that he dies.
As per the future newspaper.
I think that they'll pay off the rest
the future newspaper,
but in an unexpected way.
Because originally, like I said, it was
meant to be a crisis on infinite Earths.
It's going to be a little bit different
this time.
The whole idea is the flash
is supposed to vanish in this big crisis,
quote unquote,
in Then after the fact, Iris winds up
writing the story of the Flash,
like the story of his life as a superhero,
not giving away all of the secrets,
using her media business and winds up
winning a Pulitzer Prize for that.
And that's
what makes the flash famous, like
in the larger sense of the DC Universe.
But going forward, the whole idea is that
she raises Nora and her brother
by herself like The Flash isn't around
when they're growing up because and here's
the thing he doesn't technically die
like he kind of dies,
but he doesn't die at the same time.
My only theory
what they might wind up doing is
they'll pay off the comic book storyline
where he winds up sacrificing himself,
but he becomes the bolt of lightning that
originally gave him powers in season one.
So like electrical circuits,
like we're talking about energy here.
His life is essentially a closed loop
where he always winds up sacrifice,
seeing himself in some future catastrophe,
but then becomes the bolt of lightning
that gives him powers
so that in every timeline,
he always winds up becoming the flash.
You can let me know in the comments
how you think
they're going to end the Flash series.
But I just feel like they're going
to pay off that teacher newspaper,
meaning that he will have to disappear
and not be around in the future.
For some reason.
I know a lot of you are wondering
if he's going to have a cameo scene
in The Flash movie
because Ezra miller has a cameo seen
during Crisis on Infinite Earths.
Maybe a small scene
when the Flash is crossing
through the multiverse in the movie.
I'm not expecting like a real big scene.
I'm also really hoping
that John Wesley Shipp has some kind of
special cameo seen during the movie too.
And because of James Gunn's big DC reboot,
like them getting rid of the Arrowverse,
the whole idea is that in the future,
Green Gustin could always come back
as a multiverse version.
The Flash or is a different character
the same way that John Wesley Shipp
came back after the Nineties Flash series
as different versions of The Flash
and as Barry's father.
So just because they are kind
of getting rid of the Arrowverse
doesn't mean that grant us
and will never ever play the Flash again.
Like he could always come back in future
DC projects.
Technically all the stuff is still canon
through the multiverse in James Gunn
is just saying that all of his DC stuff
will be mostly focused around one
particular universe that's a little bit
different from the previous ones
because of what's going to happen
during the Flash movie.
The Flash movie is supposed
to reboot the larger DCU,
but not everything is going to change.
Like some actors will continue, but
the flash will be changing quote unquote.
Some stuff.
They'll draft the next trailer
for that one.
The Super Bowl comes,
so make sure you enable
alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for that new flash
trailer video and click here
for my new Kang versus The Avengers video.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and I'll see you
guys in the next one.